i think i truly am the luckiest man
alive
uh i've always thought i was the
luckiest guy you ask my wife she'll tell
you how many times i've been pulled over
and my license has been suspended two or
three times because i like speed but at
the same time like a cop will pull me
over one time my wife and i are in the
car i'm going 120 miles an hour in a 45
zone don't recommend it by the way but
i'm going in some victorville which is
not far from exactly a couple hours from
everything inserted you know that's
pretty it's a great area 120 like oh
yeah but so this guy catches me and he
pulls me over i mean that's like
120 and 45. it's not just in jail yeah
yeah they're thrown in jail so he
paul's miori comes up
he says what are you doing
i said dude i was beating you what are
you talking about are you upset he says
what
i said are you upset you couldn't catch
up is that why you're upset
what's the matter with this i'm just
joking with you i was going 120 it was a
little too fast not gonna lie to you but
i bought a new car i wanted to show my
wife a little bit of this speed i went a
little too fast he says is he always
like this
sorry officer this is how he is all the
time i'm so sorry
he's like
can i trust that if i let you go you're
not gonna drive fast again on your way
to vegas so i don't know if you should
trust it but i'm going to do my best
the cop is confused
and he says
listen man slow down but you can go and
he let me go
nah he should have given me a ticket
okay i should have gotten a ticket that
day as fast as i was going but what is
that is that a form of recklessness no
is that a i feel like a smooth talking
maybe it's smooth talking but a part of
it is also
you know i feel i'm a very lucky man i
feel i get lucky all the time
but i also feel if you want to spend a
week with me and see how i work then you
will say this guy's not lucky
so if you come around and you you run
for a month and you're gonna say yeah
i'm good
you know it'll be a certain time like
yeah guys i gotta go hit the sack okay
you guys i got two zooms to do you guys
do your thing
that's why what happens when this
happens like for me there is work after
the kids and the wife goes to sleep at
10 30. i got two and a half hours to
work right there everyone's asleep most
people are you know doing hitting the
sack themselves i got a lot of time
right there so now i don't recommend
this for everybody
but i think the concept of luck is that
when i bought the wayne gretzky am i
such a great investor
no i got a call from a guy saying
there's these two great wayne gretzky
cards in a market guy needs cash
tomorrow do you have it yes you want to
send the money i send the guy tikrun
tikrun was right you just met secret a
minute ago he went to l.a met him up at
psa we bought it at psa psa's president
showed up they said these two are legit
give them the money we gave them wired
them the money took the card sold it a
year and a half later is that because
i'm brilliant i get credit for the risk
who the hell buys a hockey card three
years ago for four years ago for
whatever the amount was nobody's
spending that kind of money okay i get
credit for the risk but i got also lucky
to get that call if i don't get that
call i didn't find that i got the call
it's a big difference i think a lot of
that's mindset though is being
optimistic to look for those
opportunities in ways that other people
might disregard and i think a lot of
those let's say you lose money in
something i think people could say oh
man i'm unlucky because that happened
and if i had done this instead it
wouldn't have happened but i think a lot
of lucky people view that as maybe an
opportunity where what did i learn from
this okay it was it was a lesson and now
that this is good that it happened
because now i'm not going to take this
to the next thing i think a lot of it is
just being optimistic i don't disagree
uh i don't disagree that a lot of it is
optimistic but
optimistic is one of them you gotta
somehow some way it's the art of being
in 50 different places at the same time
that's that's like if the market says
wait what
then weren't you just there didn't you
just do that what are you doing over
there what this is like
what the hell is going on there's so
many things that's going on like it's
the guys at five different places at the
same time if people are saying that in
the market about you
you're creating a lot of opportunities
that good things can happen to you now
let me tell you at the same time last
week three deals i wanted to go through
fell through didn't happen three deals i
wanted all these three deals didn't fall
through the week prior two deals didn't
fall through i got a pipeline up you
know 21 in my phone 21 major projects
right now that's pending that i want to
be able to do
are all of them going to close
no
are 50 i'm gonna close probably not this
year are 25 going to close this year
probably
so you're playing the odds game
and you're hoping some of them fall in
your favor but it's not always going to
happen if you enjoy this video i give a
keynote a few weeks ago in las vegas
specifically on the topic of cracking a
code to content creation if you've not
seen it click here to watch it take care
everybody bye
[Music]